an off-duty police officer stabbed to
death on the las vegas strip and the man
accused of killing him has a criminal
history the 8 news now i-team's vanessa
murphy has been digging into court
documents and is here now with more on
what she found
the alleged murder marks at least the
third arrest for freddie allen over the
past six months and this isn't the first
time he's accused of a violent crime on
the las vegas strip in fact records show
he shouldn't have even been there
saturday night he was banned from the
strip for six months from a previous
case and that time wasn't up
with a very heavy heart that we
received the news
late last night of the passing of
officer tyler steppens a visit to las
vegas ended with tyler steffen's murder
the edmonds washington police officer
was 33 years old a husband and a father
to two children the police department
noting he ranked number one at the
academy and served in the marine corps
edmonds mayor mike nelson says this is a
tough loss for the community i can't
even think of anything more horrible
than talking about
murder of a city employee
a police officer the 8 news now i-team
is learning more about the man accused
of killing stephens police say freddie
allen stabbed him on a pedestrian bridge
on the strip saturday night after an
argument with another man who police say
was loitering there over a dog the
i-team has obtained court documents
which reveal allen was just released
from jail in february last november
police say he beat a man on the strip so
badly he had to be hospitalized and
receive stitches records show judge
crystal eller sentenced him to 90 days
last september allen was arrested after
security guards on the strip said he
lunged at them with a knife two charges
were dropped and alan was convicted of
misdemeanor assault records show judge
eric goodman handed allen a suspended
sentence of 90 days and ordered him to
stay off the las vegas strip for six
months please stand up if you're
president freddie allen
allen refused to show up in court monday
morning he remains at the clark county
detention center on a murder charge what
happened to tyler was senseless
police say allen was homeless and he had
a pit bull with painted pink toenails
tourists would take photos with metro
also learned last november he had a
warrant out of arizona the original
charge was drug related his next court
date is set for wednesday we'll see if
he shows up